Hello everyone, this is my first time at JSConf,
I'm really excited to be here and talk to
you about servicerless apps powered by web
components, I just want to give a bit of context,
I work for guardian as a senior engineer,
and I work on editorialial tools, which is
the main two being the new guard yawn CMS
called composer and the new media service
for managing images, these are all built as
web apps, three tiered architecture, which
is this one, that means you is a front end,
at the front, which is the browser, and your
code running in the browser, so typically
we use Angular JS for that, then the back
end, which is the code running of your servers,
for that we usually use skyline, city natura,
play, finally the data is store in the the
database, we use elastic search, Mongo and
other things, these are typically referred
to as presentation‑‑ let me turn that
off, that's going to annoy me, people tweeting
me.
Presentation, middle tier and data storage,
this is what we're going to refer to in the
rest of the presentation, keep that in mind.
The idea for this talk came in about a few
months back when I started getting increasingly
jealous of this information‑‑ that my
colleague built, the responsetive front end
site shows a lot of information about the
health of the server, key system metrics,
KPIs, the deployment status, health service,
and so on, so that's a really useful thing
the too have at the end of your desk, compare
to what we had on my team, yeah, it was a
bit Meh, so why is it Meh, it's not just bauds
it looks a bit shit, it's also complex, it's
complex as a user, I had to be on the VPN
oaccess it, you can't log in on the VPN on
your phone, really tedious, it was also complex
as a developer, sometimes you want to change
these dashboards, if something goes bad, last
week we needed to start monitoring a new cue,
it was tedious to add new things to the dashboard,
it was deployed somewhere and written in this
horrible PHP.
The other side of that is it's also very rigid
because you only pull data from one source,
graphite, which is internal monitoring service,
and, also, the configuration was very much
mix in the with this horrible PHP that I mentioned
which made it hard to edit and manipulate
graphs the way I would like to be able to
do.
When something's not good, you put nit the
bin and you say, let's build a better one.
So, let's try and build a better one, going
back to the architecture I presented earlier,
we know that we have the data storage, this
is what data is, it can be possibly in graphite,
which is occurring, what we had for our more
legacy systems, and more and more we're moving
towards AWS, Amazon web services, which has
it's own monitoring service called Cloud watch,
that's what we're going focus on for the rest
of the presentation, that's where services
are moving, so that's where the data is, and
we know that we want to have the presentation,
layer display, the graph in your browser,
that's what we've got, now, what about this
middle tier thing.
What happens with it? Do we need it? Well,
so, I really love sky dive, more I love not
having to write any code or maintain servers
that might go down, have to monitor the monitoring,
it's boring can we get rid of it? What do
we actually need it for in the first place?
Traditionally, I think aver if Id three things
that you do on the middle tier, the first
one is Auth.
By that I mean authentication, which is know
hog the person is, and then authorization,
which is determining what their missions you
is in the system.
Once you know that they can come in, okay,
great, I can query the database on their behalf,
and retrieve some data, and once I've got
the data, I can just render it.
That's the simplest thing that the middle
tier does, and that's what wow would do if
you implement the any language.
Serverring the actual files, maybe caching,
serving data, let's leave that on the side
for now.
So, let's see, can we do all of that on the
client instead.
Let's say we have an HTML page, and we write
all of this in JavaScript.
So how do we Saturday? We start with the Auth
aspect.
Now, AWS gives us nice primitives for that,
support this idea of cry didn'tbles that you
can create, and then once you have these drew
enables, which is a key and a secret, don't
try and copy those, they're not real, and,
the region, and once you've got that you can
define the permissions that they have, so
I'm going to define these credentials, all
think can do is query Cloud watch, can't spin
up new servers and so on, all they can do
is read the metrics data.
Define them and put them in the page like,
this I have my Auth sorted.
That's in JavaScript.
Now I have my Auth, I'm going to do a query
with it.
So do that, I'm going to use the AWS JDK,
it's Open Source, you can download it.
It lets you query the Aws services you yeeuate
a new instance of the Cloud watch service
with the cree credentials we've passed in
earlier, then you can call the method to get
method statistics and define what you're querying.
Here we're going to look at the request count,
in a given load balance or given time, and
sum it.
And when we do this, asin concurrent resolution
nosily we get the response back, that's what
we see at the bottom here, that's quite, it's
AWS specific, so we might transform that,
don't look at this code, basically you transform
it into a time series, which a simple array
of pairs, and in the pair you got the first
item is the time, the event happened at and
then the second item is the value.
Very simple data structure.
So we've got our day the, we have our metrics
data, now we fled to render it.
I'm lacy, not go dog that myself, just load
in Google chat, and write this.
It's actually quite, it's quite a lot of boilerplate
here, that's what you have to do, that's from
the example on the Docs, in the middle here
we actually see that we add the rows in the
middle of this big blob of JavaScript, and
at the end we also say, okay, select this
element and then inject the graph in the page.
And then we get our graph.
That's great, okay.
Job done, let's all go to the pub.
Not quite, so we fixed the first aspect, it's
no longer complex, it's just static HTML page
in the browser, there's no VPN crap anymore,
no PHP anymore, that's sorted in terms of
rigidity we're still pulling from only one
data source, now reading from AWS that's still
only one, and the configuration was mixed
into all this spaghetti code I showed you
earlier, that's not very nice, it's not veri'
city change graphs quite rapidly.
So it's not better enough, so what can we
do? What we actually want, ideally is to not
have any of this broiler plate, we want to
say I want this graph of request, and, well,
that's sounds very much like an element, right?
Can we do that with an element? So, I'm sure
hopefully you know where I'm going with this.
Web components who in the room has heard of
web components? Cool.
Who has tried web components? Quite a lot,
great.
So, quick primer, so, web component is this
idea of custom element, so you can say there's
this Google map element that will show a map
of this Geo position, okay, if you put this
in your browser it's not going to work magically,
right, it's not going do anything.
How does it work? The idea of web components
you can teach the browser how to do‑‑
what to do with this when you see in in the
page, you can define the behavior when you
see custom element and make it do anything
you want.
All of this you program in JavaScript.
So, once you've defined‑‑ once you've
written the code for this, so that it's in
the scope, this is like you import the style
sheets to sort of change the presentation
of your page, this is simply using the HTML
import, once you have that, well, actually
all of this, in fact it doesn't really, kind
of using futuristic APIs, you need to use
poly fills, I will use platform JS, live Google
rewrite to port all the Google APIs to the
current browser.
If HTML element is your classic Lggo blocks,
this is like the Lego mind Storm, you can
do anything.
We're going to use web components we're going
to lay polymer on top of this, on top of platform
J S, you don't have to use it to use web components
you can use X tag from Mozilla if you prefer.
Let's use polymer it has a few niceties such
as these elements scaffolding, the clarity
of sin tack, we've seen this example we just
import polymers, so we can use the polymers
element to define new element called Margarita,
it takes one attribute‑‑ my greeter‑‑
and we have a tag my greeter, tag many my
name, as an attribute.
We see that the template that this is what
the‑‑ we're going to put in the shad
come DOM, basically it's what's going to appear
ton page instead of the my greeter element,
and it's going to say hello and then my name,
this is the day the binding syntax, so polymers
supports data binding, which meanness that
it's going to replace the name, sort of curly
thing with the value of the at try bud, here
Seb, and because it's bidirectional, you can
also bind it to this input text, where it's
going to give the initial value to the input
text Seb, if you change it ill will change
it everywhere for this variable.
That's powerful.
And we're going to use it throughout the rest
of this presentation.
Okay, so, will's dive in.
Or not ...
oh, here we go.
So we've got this Aws con fig element.
We've created a few element AWS‑Config.
It takes three attributes, region key and
secret.
We just pass in key values to the at try brute.
What do these elements do? Nothing, not useful.
Nothing to display, it's just a configuration
thing, what do we cowith it? We add a new
attribute, we call it Sync, an at try brute
we're going to write out what sort of the
out put of the element is as data here we're
going to out put to AWS‑Co infig, which
is what we had earlier in the JavaScript,
so actually, if you go to the implementation
it looks similar to what we did earlier.
We load in polymers, A W S‑Config with four
attributes then I declare how this element
works, I'm observing the first three attributes,
the first three inputs, when ever any of it
changes I'm going to update.
I'm also going to update when the element
is ready, it's been put in the page.
What does update do? It just checks that the
three inputs are there, if they R.
create a new object and write it‑‑ sort
of assign it to the same property which will
basically set it to this variable that we
day bound.
So, I have this element, by the way, all of
this is Open Source, it's GitHub, so you can
play with this, you can just make your own.
So we've got our credentials now as a variable,
so we can pass it in to this Cloud watch element,
extract same JavaScript element we had earlier,
which, does the querying using the SDK, not
going show you the code for that, basically
we have this element that takes the con give
as input, it's going to have it's own sing
attribute that will write asin concurrent
resolution nosily when the day the comes back,
write the into the variable, that's going
to contain time series, you mass AWS dimension,
just the same way you do like an option inside
a select for instance.
So we have our data and it looks very much
like what we had before.
Of‑‑ is this thing working? It looks
like what we had before, which is this time
series data, we can pass it in to the render
element.
Now, actually, because I'm super Lazy, I'm
not going to write it, I'll steal it from
Google, Google wrote their own chart element
testimony wraps their Google chat library
there's a lot less of this horrible boilerplate
than before, that's already a nice win.
Just passing in my data, define how it's going
to look, and, there we go, we've got our chart,
so that's cool.
And, weave got all of this through web components,
so what does it look likened to end, end to
end we have‑‑ weave got our three‑string
attributes that we pass into the AWS config
element, that will write it to a new variable,
we pass that to Cloud watch alongside parameters,
do the Ajax request, we can write that into
another variable and pass to Google chart
and boom chart appears, great, what does this
look like in code, very similar in fact, we
load in platform JS at the top, which is the
poly fill, we import our three elements, we
use them in our auto binding context that
gives us the data binding thing, that's it,
this is three elements, that works for single
chart.
If we end up having more chart, more request
charts you can already tell that it's going
to take quite a lot of courage.
Went up with a something like this, a lot
of code application, adopt repeat yourself,
not clean to pop I paste code if you're doing
it, you're doing it wrong probably.
How do you abstract this? When typical programming
you paramettize it as a function, right, then
bits that change you make them parameters
of the function and abstracted it way way.
You're going to use an element instead, maybee
make the two input, the config, and load banner
which is the only thing that change in the
code, question abstract it to an Aws element
and just pass in the load balance, and then
we can use it and it's done what we want it,
with have the Aws element, and request a draft
for the load‑‑ great, we've done it
for requests, we can show latent say, you
can show like bucketed numbers of accounts,
you can do anything you want.
And because weave based that on small awe
Tommic modules you can replace some of the
piece of the puzzle.
You can say, let's fetch the data from another
source, let's fetch day from graphite instead
of AWS Cloud watch, it's a completely different
server, but, because we out put this in the
same data format‑‑ interesting.
(Laughing) that's how impressive web components
are (Laughing) because we use the same data
form mat we can pass it into the Google chat
and it works just the same.
So, a small confession weave actually cheated
all along, everywhere we pass in the the exact
sort of string values for the time, well,
that's a bit stupid, that means we're also
watching a given sort of time range, time
interval for all our data, that's not a very
useful graph.
So what can we do instead? So, what we‑‑
what do we want, we want to say just the last
hour of data, so how do we do that? Well,
the last hour of data means that the time
interval, ends now.
So, we're just going to create new variables
with the now time, where does now come from,
there's an element for that, just create the
new time element, that's going to export the
time, when it Eastern initialized and the
time, the now variable will store a date time
that is passed into the Cloud watch element
that's great, except that it's just‑‑
it doesn't update.
We can make it update, we can pass this a
refresh attribute that says update every minute.
That means that actually the nice thing here
is that of when now updates after a minute,
the now value changes and because Cloud watches
also observing these inputs is going to update,
is going to do another request to fetch the
updated data, and because the charting elementals
watches its inputs, it's going to update the
graph.
It's like functional reactive programming
where you define the data flow and then everything
updates without having to explicitly listen
for special vents, nobody knows about the
other things happening, it's just day the
bound.
We're not quite done yet because the start
time is still hard coded, so what we said
we wanted to have a‑‑ time interval
of one hour, so, let's do that, let's define
a time range, el.
That says one hour and then we bind the end
to now, which means that the start is going
to be an output, which will be‑‑ can
attach to Cloud watch element.
We've got now our time range of one hour,
that's enforced, when it start changes, except
we're still not done the number of hours is
fixed, what do we want? We probably want a
custom number of hours what if your service
died a horrible death an hour and half ago,
we want to do change.time range.
So if you said the user needs to do it, we
need offI element, I'm Lazy, I'm not going
to write my own, steel this one from gage
Google that's what they're for, we take the
paper ment, and that's going to export a simple
integer value that we're going to bind as
ours, when I change the value here as you
see in the give, that changes the number of
hours, the same way as when now changes, that
cascades down, changes the data and renders
again.
If you change the number of hours as a user,
it just cascades down and changes what you
see in the graph automatically .
so that's pretty neat.
This is what the code looks like, you can
review this later.
Another thing we did, which we cheated a bit
on is we've hard coded secret in the page.
Now if you are security expert even if you're
not, this is not a good thing to do, you don't
want to put secrets in the page if someone
sees that page, that means they can access
your‑‑ well, they can query how slow
your service are, not souper dangerous, still
not a nice thing to do, probably don't want
do that.
How do you do that, you need to awe then the
Kate with your servers.
Well, what we can do is we can use this magical
thing with the AWS web identity federation,
this is provide by the AWS, and it lets you
acquire a talk with a third party or with
a provider like Google, Facebook, or Amazon,
and then you said that token for temporary
set of cry didn'tbles that you can define
permissions for this is what I've done here,
weave written a new AWS I deputy element that
wraps the Google element that Google provided
they had to writ for me, so that's nice.
That expose the same AWS config object as
the previous element did, you can substitute
the hard coded con fig we had previously with
this one that does it in a safer way and without
revoling any secrets, so, that's nice.
So let's do live Demo.
(Laughing) maybe.
Okay.
So, let's see if it still works this is a
demo ready to have made.
You see on the right there is tag API metrics,
they appear here, they fetch from graphite
is simply I P based I have to be on the VPN
for this.
And other thing we see is these weird rounded
colored dots and these represent deploy either
proproduction or preproduction environment
where whether they succeeded or failed.
This is day that's live from today, from now.
And, so, as said, we're going to use AWS identity
element to do the Auth so this is the Google
sign in element, in is what it looks like,
this is the button for it.
I'm just going to need Auth with Google, and
that creates a tocken, trades it with Amazon
and gets a set of credential, everything is
data bound, the data appears here magically
so we can see things like this, you the latency,
request, and‑‑ this is a static page,
this is just a Python server, static HTML
file‑‑ and this' all using web components.
(applause) you can change that, you can change
what time window, it automatically updates
just through the magic of data binding, that's
also neat, you don't have to write complex
logic to update.
That's the demo.
So does that mean we can all say Fuck server
I'm just going to write JavaScript code if
now on and don't need to do anymore server,
I'm just going to talk today that base from
the end of times no? Not quite partly because
well, it's‑‑ well, if you use the web
components the support is still fairly limited,
it doesn't support all browsers, especially
all the browsers, and you might want to support
that.
The other thing is, as we saw, querying the
database directly from the browser that doesn't
really scale very well, so for things with
low traffic like something that develops use
or internal users use, thattest a fine you
can use that, but I wouldn't put that on the
front of the Guardian web site, I don't think
Patrick would like that much.
That would not scale very well.
The other thing is we want to have a system
for authentication, especially if you're doing
read/write, even reading sensitive data like
this.
For this the only sort of component you can
rely on is the back end, you can't rely on
the front end for that, anyone can write it.
So, you need support from your back end services,
and you can do that with IP restrictions or
do with that things like AWS policies, but
the policies are quite course grain, you can
only say‑‑ this column in this database,
so there's limitations that make it a bit
harder to use for write services, you can
still do it for things like this, and quite
a lot of other cases.
6 in the future I think there's more things
we want to do with the dashboard, this is
the beginning, showing deploy lines on graphs,
like how many immanages I add every day, surfacing
JavaScript, we use the century service to
coupe them, great to see when there's a spike
after deploy.
And see the server hayseed, a lot particular
things you can add to the servers carrying
on the same pattern.
What have we learned so far? I think we've
seen that it's possible to remove this middle
tier, that makes the whole system a lot simpler
to maintain to edit.
It works in a variety of cases.
The other Inc.
this we've learn is that you can use web components
as atomic programmable blocks like Lego blocks,
then you can combine them using data binding
or composition or events and that lets you
create quite a complex system out of very
simple blocks that you can then substitute.
So that's what I've got, and as said, all
of this is Open Source, you can check it out,
so I recommend you go and play with it, find
bug reports and everything and play with it
at home, it's safe that's all.
Thank you very much (Applause)